faciliter la recherche d'emploi des
personnes handicapées c'est la démarche
de ce forum qui s'est tenu ce jeudi à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et où une trentaine d'entreprises du
territoire étaient présentes
l'idée est de permettre à ces demandeurs
d'emploi de passer plus de temps avec
des recruteurs potentiels pour
multiplier leurs chances dans gauche et
de pouvoir centraliser leurs démarches
nous avons en effet une demande des
entreprises qui porte sur des emplois
qui sont relativement qualifiés et nous
avons des travailleurs handicapés qui
sont en très grand nombre en situation
de sous-emploi ou de non emploi etc
public à un faible niveau de
qualification donc vraiment un problème
d'adéquation entre l'offre et la demande
d'emploi
ce sont des entreprises qui qui ont eu
une volonté d'embaucher des travailleurs
handicapés pour remplir leurs
leur quota de 6% j'ai déjà fait un forum
comme ça à paris et il ya beaucoup moins
de monde
stand travailleurs handicapés donc on
peut en faire beaucoup plus la loi
oblige en effet les entreprises de plus
de 20 salariés a recruté six pour cent
de son personnel handicapé un taux peu
respectés en france qui donne lieu à une
amende verser à l'agefiph
mais certains groupes ou près de la
vence comme la poste venu recruter des
facteurs guichetiers conseillers
financiers
la poste aujourd'hui est capable
d'aménager un certain nombre de
dispositifs que ce soit dès l'entrée en
sélection puisque aujourd'hui on est en
capacité d'aménager les tests de
sélection
on est aussi en capacité d'aménager les
dispositifs de formation professionnelle
et bien sûr à terme mais aussi une
capacité d'aménager deux les postes de
travail la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisera à
nouveau un forum emploi handicap lors de
la semaine de l'emploi en février
prochain